THAN HIM IN LA COLOURS IS DUSTIN
BROWN, WHO IS ON THE SHELF NOW.
WE'RE UNDERWAY IN WINNIPEG.
GLAD TO HAVE YOU WITH USATTACK,R
TURNS IT OVER, ARVIDSSON TAKES A
CHANCE, OPPORTUNITY, THAT REDIR
TURNED ASIDE BY HELLEBUYCK.
LOOSE PUCKWIDE, SPENCE,
NEAR SIDE, TURNED ASIDE BY  TO
REBOUND, AND THE KINGS, DOWN A
MAN, GET AWESOME JOB GOING TO TE
NET, HARD, COLLECTS THE PUCK
QUICKLY AND JUST SHOVELS IT OVE
KOPITAR TAKES A LOOK, STOPPED BY
HELLEBUYCK, BIG SAVE THERE, AS
KOPITAR WITH A CHANCE SHORT CHE
DANAULT, GETS THE GOOD STICK ON
THAT, UNDERSTANDS THERE IS AN  !
PETERSON CAME ACROSS TO KEEP SH
STRIDE, ALBOUND, BACK
HAND, WIDE BY LOWRY.
BACK IN FRONT, PASSREBOUND,
SCORES! IT?
HIS 1,058 POINT IN HIS CAREER,
OPPED TOO.
TWO GOOD SAVES BY HELLEBUYCK,
AND HE THE RETURN PASS
FROM SPENCE, JUST LOOKING FOR A.
IT'S A POWER PLAY GOAL THAT
S M
AROUND AND
BREAK AWAY FROM HIS OWN BLUE
LINE, SHUTIGH
AND BOUNCES NEAR SIDE.
SVECHNIKOV BACK ON IT
BY SEAN DURZI LED TO AN
OPPORTUNITY, AND HELLEBUYCK HAD
TO BE SHARP TO MAKE THAE
VETERAN PLAYERS, WHEELER TURNS
THE PUCK OVER, OFF TOONE.
THE POWER PLAY WAS HUMMING, THE
PETERSON, A THE
CONTROL OFF THE DRAW AND FIRE IT
DOWN THE ICE.
LOOKING FOR A TIP, STOP,
SCHEIFELE, STOPPED,
POST.
A GREAT ONE-TIMER BY SCHEIFELE,
SECOND CHANCE BY BARREN, TWO BIG
SAVES BY CAL PETERSON.TSNET AND,
MOORE TOOKOKTHROUGH,
STOPPED BY HELLEBUYCK, STOPPED
THE REBOUND TOO.
HE WENT WITH THE POKE AS
HELLEBUYCK DOES A NICE JOB
PUTTING OUT THE STICK TO POKE
CHECK.